plus nicolas bedos
bordeaux
juliette parce que ça leur m'a dit il
mais bon imm be ge et j'ai des nausées
je ne vois pas vomir je suis hardy sion
à peine arrivé mais bon voilà mais je
vais me tenir la droite a pris quoi du
lexomil du tranxène du valium du xanax
je peux dire la vérité
oui j'ai pris un quart l'exo un cas
voilà voilà
parce que je suis terrorisée voilà je
suis meilleur à à l'écrit qu'à l'oral je
crois dans ton métier c'est mieux un nom
je suis là mais je suis content en tous
les cas tu as fait un sacré portrait de
ton père je suppose que c'est un
portrait de mon père de la guerre lancée
en tout cas non mais on est traversé par
fars
je pense que quand un jeune romancier
écrit un premier livre un premier roman
ils règlent des comptes il pense à son
passé à ses anciennes petites amies à
ses parents moi ce qui est plus pervers
de la situation c'est que je lui fais
jouer le personnage avec lequel parfois
je règle non pas des comptes mais enfin
c'est pas une c'est pas un miroir très
complaisant gecas qu'est-ce qui est très
touchant dans l'histoire c'est que toi
tu avais peur de lui faire lire la pièce
que tu avais peur ça lui plaise pas lui
là ils avaient peur de la massacrer en
la jouant donc à une espèce de pudeur
entre vous qui était assez touchante
c'est à dire que voilà on est par
exemple la sinne 1 à côté d'autres moi
si je regardais ma télé je me dirais
voilà il ya le fils de à côté de son
papa
ça m'agace ray enfin donc on avait envie
d'éviter ça parce que je sais pas ce
qu'en pensent les gens qui sont contre à
nous regarder mais moi je trouve le
grand le gant le grand couillon à côté
de son papa qui a écrit mme pieza mais
voilà il faut que je vienne au théâtre
avec la pièce était mauvaise foi
terrible mais c'est comme marilou berry
était une bonne comédienne voilà qu'elle
soit la fille de balasko tout le monde
s'en fou qui d'autre aurait pu jouer la
pièce michel serrault jean louis
trintignant
je lui proposais jean louis trintignant
c'est vrai qu'on a on a en a on a voulu
éviter ça sert qu'en écrivant je savais
qu'il la joue très très bien mais ce
monsieur
et puis on a voulu éviter ça alors je
les proposer à jean louis trintignant
qui m'a fait l'amitié de sanaa
énormément flatter parce que ça les
intéressait et donc j'ai reçu c'est un
grand de lettres que je vois là que je
garderai toujours placardées dans la
chambre de jean louis trintignant
m'expliquant que oui peut-être mais et
voilà il pensait qu'il avait pas
l'humanité et la drôlerie qui pourrait
permettre à ce vieux
de montceau de séduire et de et de
d'être supportés par le public parce que
quand même ça commence hard c'est très
acide et il fallait toute l'humanité de
ce monsieur pour faire avaler la pilule
mais arrête de m'appeler monsieur quand
même tu exagères ça va faire très chaud
au coeur quand sa progéniture vous
propose d'une création comme sade
d'entrer dans son univers m'amuser en
plus c'est que c'était un peu un message
que j'ai envoyée à cette époque là je
vous aime parce que le personnage de la
pièce en fait est un est un personnage
qui en fait ont complètement comme vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure avec le genre
léger avec l'humour avec leurs rires
avec tout ce qui pourrait à un moment
donné le le culpabiliser de ne pas
parler des affaires du monde et ça fait
chier tout le monde d'ailleurs parce que
l'on ne passe son temps à lui demander
de revenir vers quelque chose de plus
efficace et je crois qu'au moment où
j'ai écrit cette pièce j'avais aussi
envie de dire à moi mon père d'une
certaine façon ce que je pense qu'il est
parfois de tenter par le sérieux et par
la gravité et il le fait d'ailleurs
assez bien mais j'avais aussi envie de
le ramener vers vers vers le spectacle
vers le ver le vers le plaisir du vers
le 20 juin vers la différence
essentielle entre le personnage que je
jouais et moi c'est que moi mes colères
les indignations mes convictions et ses
jets émises dans maison à l'oracle et
les salles sont pleines et plus ou moins
donc j'ai aucune raison il n'y a pas de
rupture il n'y a pas de rupture ce
n'était pas de fracture tu as deux
phrases terribles
la première c'est il sait faire du du
drôle avec du triste qui est formidable
et l'autre je suis entré dans mes années
courte c'est à dire quoi que j'ai 70 ans
et que logiquement bah voila quoi jeu
et je me donne
pour vivre comme j'aime c'est à dire
pareil car je vis exactement de la même
façon fonctionne de la même façon que
quand j'avais 30 40 ans etc
et pour cause parce que voilà j'ai pas
le droit de faire autrement
mais il ya un moment où je vais devenir
politique et j'aimerais sortir avant
mais génétiquement dans sa famille on
vise 3 99 on en parlera quand tu feras
mémoire d'outre-mer oui tu reviendras
oui jian oui je vais j'y allais pugétois
c'est ça oui pascaline moins drôle ce
soir ça